salut aujourd'hui on est mercredi c'est
le jour de l'astuce du mercredi comme
vous pouvez le constater les 14h48 je
dois partir à 16 heures de chez moi donc
je suis grave grave à la bourre décider
quelle vidéo j'allais faire j'ai pris ce
matin le cahier à idées le cahier qui
comporte les idées que vous me donnez
souvent en commentaires sur youtube et
que je note précieusement ici en
précieux cahier
ça m'a permis de trouver le thème de
cette vidéo là est aussi le thème du
master class de samedi je vous dise je
vous le dis à la fin je pense vraiment
que ça va vous plaire nardi vous le
saviez y avait mon plateau hallucination
collective et autres illusions
fantastique et b aujourd'hui je vous
parlais d'illusions vous allez vous
faire halluciner vous même grâce à des
illusions en 60 ans réel soit d'optique
soit autres 5 illusion donc pour ce
mercredi la première illusion c'est
quelque chose que vous allez vous faire
à vous même vous même tout seul ça va
être dans votre tête avoue ça s'appelle
l'apparition de la saucisse je vais vous
aider à faire paraître une saucisse
n'existe pas alors ça peut être une
hutte naquit bol ça peut être une
saucisse de bonne taille ça va être à
vous d'en décider pour ça vous allez y
visionner vos yeux et votre cerveau et
c'est pas très compliqué vous mettez un
doigt comme ça l'autre doit comme ça et
voulait rapprocher relativement proches
et vous allez utiliser ce qu'on appelle
la vision lointaine vous allez regarder
plus loin c'est comme si je mettais ma
main là et que je cherchais à regarder
les livres qui a derrière vous savez on
a la vision qui se trouble qui se
dédoublent un petit peu à ce moment là
c'est exactement ce qu'on recherche une
fois que vous avez placé vaudois et que
vous regardez le lointain que vous
regardez derrière vous allez bouger un
petit peu les doigts jusqu'à temps que
vous voyez apparaître une saucisse une
saucisse qui flottent en l'air ceci ce
qui est relié à rien c'est quand même
fou voilà mois ses distances je
l'associé selon rose mais aussi de bonne
taille j'écarte un petit peu mais doit
forcément ça devient une petite jackie
ball et si je la rapproche la faire
grandir la saucisse et je peux bouger au
site d'avant en arrière voilà vous vous
autorise youn et vous vous double fait
mais je trouve ça très drôle à faire ça
me fait quand même particulièrement rire
de vous faire une vidéo à base de
saucisses la deuxième illusion elle est
très rigolote elle va jouer sur la
persistance rétinienne je vais vous
faire voir une image maintenant comme
vous pouvez le constater ci l'image de
mon affiche de mon spectacle
celui qui est en tournée actuellement
vous allez fixé le point rouge que j'ai
mis sur mon affiche vous le fixe et vous
ne le lâchez pas des yeux pour l'instant
ne clignez pas des yeux si possible vous
bougez pas les yeux vous fixé ce point
rouge tout le temps ce point rouge
vous ne bougez pas vous le fixe et c'est
bien normal et je claque des doigts et
je change d'affiche vous voyez toutes
ces belles couleurs et b si vous bougez
les yeux vous ne les verrez plus vous
allez avoir l'impression que la fiche et
en noir et blanc parce que oui oui
l'affiché était en noir et blanc vous
pouvez revenir en arrière pour le
vérifier c'est ce qu'on appelle la
persistance rétinienne vous avez joué au
photographe en développant vous même on
affiche troisième astuces cascades vous
allez de nouveau vous auto ou
illusionner vous auto bleue fait vous
auto optic et tout ce que vous voulez
mais avec un autre sens celui du toucher
vous devez prendre un petit objet rond
dans l'idéal une biya on n'a pas
toujours une vie chez soi moi j'ai
essayé avec inde et ça fonctionne très
très bien c'est une bille carrés avec
des chiffres dessus en fait
mais si vous avez une fille ou quelque
chose de ce ferry qu'en fait et de pas
trop grand ce sera beaucoup mieux pour
le faire je le recommande c'est encore
plus bluffant pour cette troisième
astuces autoweek fusionnant que vous
mettez vos doigts comme ceux-ci ok vous
passez un doigt l'un sur l'autre et vous
allez poser vos doigts sur l'objet
l'idée c'est de mettre en contact le
bout des doigts sur la surface de
l'objet
vous faites comme ça et vous regarder à
côté vous commencé à bouger un petit peu
les doigts sur la surface c'est
important que les deux bouts de doigts
ça toujours en contact en même temps
avec la surface et plus vous allez
appuyer et bouger un petit peu juste
comme ça que vous allez avoir la
sensation qui a deux objets sous vos
doigts deux objets distincts comme s'il
y avait un vide entre vos doigts alors
avec le d moi j'ai l'impression d'avoir
un petit peu de d en plus j'avais pas
pensé à ça mais c'est tout à fait
contradictoire avec l'information de
l'autre main qui elle ne sent qu'un seul
objet c'est très drôle à faire je le
fais sur le 3 vous pouvez le faire sur
un autre chiffre
ça marche très bien aussi et si vous le
faites avec une big alors là c'est
formidable parce que vous pouvez la
faire rouler comme ça et l'illusion a
déterré vous avez l'impression la
sensation d'avoir 2 bis au bout des
doigts même si vous regardez après ça
fait pas peur de la sensation c'est
vraiment une astuce auto elisio nantes
auto bluffante quatrième as tu juste je
crois que je commence à craquer je vais
vous aider à faire disparaître un point
ce que vous voulez en fait prenez une
feuille prenez un stylo à mark hurd peu
importe
et vous faites un point de chaque côté
de la feuille les deux points doivent
être espacés d'environ 6 cm et demie 7
cm il ya deux écoles
le ensuite vous placer cette feuille
devant vos yeux vous fermer l'oeil
gauche avec l'oeil droit vous regarder
uniquement le point de gauche que vous
avez fait tout en faisant ça vous allez
approcher la feuille de vente est un
moment très précis qui se situe à peu
près à 15 cm entre la feuille et votre
visage le point qui à droite va
disparaître vous avez pu le voir du tout
noté aussi que ça marche à l'inversé si
vous fermer l'oeil droit et que vous
gardez l'oeil gauche ouverts et que avec
les gauches vous regardez le poing droit
en accrochant voilà là exactement ce
moment là je ne vois plus le pont si
vous voulez en se font en direct je vous
mets ça devant voilà vous fermez votre
gauche avec votre oeil droit vous
regarder uniquement le point de gauche
vous approchez vous approcher le nez de
l'écran les ja prochaine et de l'écran
n'ayez pas peur approcher et un moment
très précis en faisant lentement vous
allez constater que le point de droite
va disparaître approchez approchez
approchez désolé j'ai pas pu m'empêcher
ça fonctionne grâce à un point qu'on
connaît bien en fait qui s'appelle le
point aveugle c'est l'endroit précis
dans l'oeil vous n'y a pas de
photorécepteurs en fait y en a pas parce
que c'est un peu comme un petit trou en
fait où passent tous les vaisseaux
sanguins est le nerf optique
donc forcément le cerveau comble avec ce
qui se souvient de l'image qui est
cohérent en fait notre cerveau nous ment
à ce moment là c'est très drôle parce
qu'on s'en rend pas compte
et on va terminer avec deux illusions
d'optique une sur le mouvement et une
autre sur la perception
elles ne sont pas de moi elles sont du
professeur qui t'as qu'à de l'université
de kyoto
la première c'est celle ci regardez la
bien je vous le dis rien ne bouge
et si vous me croyez pas vous mettez
pause et vous allez voir que ça continue
de bouger quand même pour vous et la
deuxième je la trouve particulièrement
bluffant c'est à dire que même moi qui
la connaît j'ai été obligé je jure que
c'est vrai de vérifier à la règle
regardez bien cette image vous pouvez
vérifier et l'imprimé toutes les lignes
sont droites et parallèle entre elles
toutes les lignes de ce dessin sans
droite et parallèles n'y a pas de courbe
il n'y a pas de choses comme ça bravo
professeur qui t'as qu'à voilà c'était
l'astuce du mercredi je reste pas
beaucoup plus longtemps avec vous parce
qu'il faut que je la monte et que je la
mette en ligne j'ai quand même une
annonce le master class que je vais
faire samedi
c'est par rapport à des commentaires que
j'ai eus bonne vingtaine de fois je
crois sur la vidéo youtube
je vais vous apprendre à compter les
cartes au blackjack voilà on va faire un
master class de 10 15 minutes là dessus
et à la fin vous serez toutes les
techniques toute la méthodologie pour
pouvoir compter les cartes sur le jeu du
blackjack demain je lance la première
vidéo en mode je parle de ce que je veux
vendredi je crois que je tourne avec
karim duval une vidéo tas pour info je
vous annonce la semaine bleue voilà je
suis parti à vous l'annoncer
samedi je viens de vous le dire et
dimanche je sais pas encore ce que je
ferai comme explication de la semaine si
cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas un
pouce en l'air un petit partage et
surtout abonnez-vous à la chaîne c'est
très très important abonnez-vous on est
de plus en plus nombreux et ça c'est
grâce à vos partages c'est vraiment cool
objectif de 1500 abonnés à 2500 abonnés
on se fait à live ensemble durant deux
trois heures je mets ça en place et j'ai
vraiment hâte que ça arrive donc abonnez
vous et amenez vos potes on se retrouve
demain pour le prochain mentale vlog
ciao